so before we get into the new stuff
Deadpool 2 is a sequel that makes a
whole lot of callbacks to the first film
so let's get caught up in the opening
voiceover Deadpool called his first
movie a love story and because he
apparently loves symmetry this time he
lets us know right off that we're
watching a family film what genre will
Deadpool 3 be maybe he has to take over
and turn around a troubled day care
center or peewee hockey team perhaps he
and cable will set off on a hilarious
road trip to Vegas where literally
everything that can go wrong does go
wrong we'll just have to wait and see
early on we see a knife sticking out of
Wade's wall could this be the same one
that got lodged in his head during the
first movies climax probably yeah
he's a sentimental guy of course the
skee-ball token that Wade gives Vanessa
harkens back to their first date which
we saw depicted in the original movie
Deadpool mourns at one point for George
Michael's passing picking up on his love
of Wham from the first film but most
brilliantly clever of all in Deadpool 1
our Merc sarcastically tells blind al
before venturing off possibly to his
death that he's buried 116 kilos of
cocaine and the cure for blindness in
his apartment somewhere in Deadpool 2 we
see him on earth the stache and sure
enough there's a package down there
reading cure for blindness way to make
us wait for it guys my goodness there's
a lot of comic book references in this
movie I mean it's Deadpool and he's
known for being meta and this is the
sequel where things get even more meta
but still wow this this is meta we open
on a music box inspired by the grisly
finale of 2017 s Logan throughout the
movie Deadpool likes to take credit for
kicking off the r-rated comic book crazy
because blade and kick-ass and wanted
and Dredd and The Crow and Sin City and
Kingsman and Constantine and Punisher
war zone and Watchmen and they don't
count that last one has wall-to-wall
visible Dawg - they should get bonus
points did anyone else think that when
mr. pool takes out his toaster pastry he
seems to fling it a bit like the famed
x-man gambit no no one else okay fine
just me speaking of the x-men a whole
bunch of them actually show up this time
one way it's walking around the mansion
wondering why it's always so abandoned
saved for colossus and negasonic teenage
warhead we see a small room just out of
his view containing a number of foxes
favorite mutants including James McAvoy
as Professor X and Nicholas Hoult as
beasts but not Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
though let him rest
Oh also Deadpool at one point asks after
the mutant he caused the putz with
penguin wings he probably means Warren
Worthington the third who was originally
known as angel but then later became arc
angel when he switched over to smooth
penguin lake metallic wings Deadpool and
his ex friends go to save young Russell
Collins who likes to call himself fire
fist this is actually a character from
Marvel Comics who appeared frequently in
the x-factor x-force and New Mutants
series his origin story was pretty
similar not knowing how to control his
mutant powers he accidentally burned a
woman to death and was arrested only to
be saved by x-factor it wouldn't be a
Deadpool movie without at least one
knock-on co-creator Rob Liefeld in this
case Deadpool wonders aloud who would
possibly think of making luck a
superpower and muses that it's probably
a guy who can't draw feet this is a
constant criticism made of Liefeld's
drawing a line and has been the subject
of numerous blog posts and jokes
Russell's been held at a brutal home for
mutants called Essex House
now this isn't from the comics but the
iconic x-men villain mr. Sinister's real
name is Nathaniel Essex so perhaps it's
a shout out speaking of characters who
aren't from the comics Yukio now there
is a character named Yukio but she's a
ninja and doesn't have any electricity
related mutant powers in fact a
character from the 2013 Fox Marvel movie
The Wolverine was based on her of course
all those dear departed x-force
characters riff on real Marvel
properties and so does the inmate black
Tom Cassidy in the comics his mutant
powers let him bond with and control
plant life basically making him Marvel's
version of poison ivy only you know sex
here also in the comics he frequently
works alongside juggernaut they don't
quite get along as well here speaking of
juggernaut did you catch Deadpool's
attempted use of Suns getting real low
big guy to calm him down
this of course references black widows
technique for managing the
hulks rages in Avengers age of Ultron
Plus that wild chase scene finally
brings Deadpool's beloved scooter to the
big screen it happens on a road called
Jerry Duggan Parkway a nod to comic book
writer Jerry Duggan who relaunched
Deadpool's comic book title in 2013
along with brian post saying during that
same chase we also pass a mural with
stan lee's image on it this film's
version of his cameo and an ice-cream
truck called Pryor's treats this
probably riffs on the name Madeleine
Pryor who is a clone of Jean Grey and
cables mother from Marvel Comics
Deadpool's failed attempt to block a
hail of gunfire coming his way is a
direct nod to his early appearance in
x-men origins Wolverine when Ryan
Reynolds more successfully pulled off
the same maneuver and it's not just
Marvel getting the meta treatment the
film features not one but two shout outs
to Tim Burton's 1989 Batman movie
Deadpool uses Michael Keaton's I'm
Batman
catchphrase and the Joker's bang gun can
be seen behind weasels head during the
x-force auditions early on Deadpool
tells Vanessa that he got tied up in a
fight with another superhero whose mom's
name is Martha take that Batman V
Superman hard to believe no one has made
a joke about that movie until right now
huh
enough references you say can't take any
more
well toughen up buttercup because those
were just the riffs on comic books
Deadpool can't get enough pop-culture
jokes either first off Vanisher is Brad
Pitt you guys Brad Pitt in a Deadpool
movie what a time to be alive to back up
a bit the opening credits riff of course
on James Bond films and did you catch
that the director is listed as one of
the guys who killed John Wick's dog this
is true director david leitch previously
held the first John wick movie alongside
Chad stole a ski clap bastard the movie
features not one but two Tom Cruise
movie references Deadpool tells dopinder
talk to me goose which maverick says to
his partner and Top Gun and later
dopinder becomes fixated on Kirsten
Dunst from interview with the vampire
yes it's pronounced Kirsten you know who
else was in an interview with the
vampire Brad Pitt so wait hang on that
means that the
actor Brad Pitt exists in the Fox Marvel
fictional universe because he's in
interview with the vampire
so he's Brad Pitt the actor also the
Vanisher and is he dead now in Marvel
continuity
well that's very upsetting blind al
encourages way to just keep living and
he responds by calling her Matthew
McConaughey this was McConaughey's big
catch phrase as Wooderson and Dazed and
Confused and it's also the name of his
Charitable Foundation
isn't that nice this sort of makes up
for those Lincoln ads almost the bit
where Deadpool tries to woo back
Colossus by blasting Peter Gabriel
outside the x-mansion references 80s
teen classics say anything and Deadpool
urging Colossus to sweep the leg Johnny
during his fight with the juggernaut
references 80s teen classic Karate Kid
so at least they're consistent oh also
DP calls negasonic teenage warhead 11 in
the post-credits scene riffing on
stranger things because he's very
current also this franchise is now
officially a time hopping adventure and
I couldn't be more excited I'll be
honest with you as we're going to press
publish on this very video there are a
few things we still just don't know we
tried our best but no one was talking
for example you know those two rednecks
Cable encounters when he first travels
back to our time he steals their truck
but they get to keep their boots in
their clothes one of them is played by
alan tudyk of firefly and rogue one Fame
and the other is credited as Dickie
green bat who is not a real person and
which is seemingly a riff on Jude Law's
name from the talented mr. Ripley Dickie
Greenleaf so who is that actor also who
is the juggernaut he's in the credits as
playing himself which means in the Fox
x-men universe Brad Pitt coexists with
the juggernaut reply to this video and
let us know what you think who was the
voice of the juggernaut and why do you
think it was definitely Brad Pitt